you look at the statistics of how much
time kids are spending with their
parents these days it's like 35 minutes
a day that's it when you remove bathing
making dinner when you are face to face
with your kid bonding doing an activity
where you are interacting that's an
average of 35 minutes a day the benefit
of homeschooling is the opportunities
and the freedom that you do have I
didn't have to finish all my classes by
a certain period I had nine months if I
wanted to get everything done in two
weeks I could have I had so much
flexibility to do everything that I was
interested in I took art classes I did
gymnastics I volunteered and that was
only because I had the time to do it I
was not in school until 3 P.M I spent so
much time with my family my relationship
with my mom is one of the things that
I'm most proud of I inherited a lot of
her values because I spent so much
quality time with her that she was the
one who raised me not a teacher and I
think that that is so important because